bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt fonce alors on vient de le
voir la campagne de vaccination a débuté
aujourd'hui en france elle sera
véritablement lancée en janvier quand
espérez-vous en voir les effets sur les
services d'urgences hospitalières ça va
être quelque chose de progressif il faut
atteindre un seuil de vaccination
relativement important il faudrait qu on
est vacciné probablement au moins 50
chansons pour cent des personnes
fragiles et quand les vaccinés 50 ou 60%
de la population pour qu'on puisse
s'attendre à vraiment avec les
producteurs du vaccin mais c'est
vraiment une immense nouvelle
je comprends qu'il peut y avoir une
certaine crainte de la part de la
population vis-à-vis d'un nouveau
produit pharmaceutique
un vaccin c'est un produit
pharmaceutique mais c'est d'une immense
nouvelle c'est un grand soulagement
c'est vraiment le couronnement d'une
compagnie scientifique inédite dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
il faut que nous soyons très optimiste
mais que chaque français chacun de nos
concitoyens comprennent l'importance de
cette campagne vaccinale pour pourvoir
retrouver un mode de vie le plus proche
possible de société l'autre lot de
depuis habituel alors justement on
l'avait dans des sondages un récent 1
les français qui sont plutôt réticents à
l'idée de se faire vacciner est ce que
vous avez une crainte de ce côté là bien
sûr qu'il y a une certaine crainte au
mais je pense que les anti vaccins ce
qu'on appelle vraiment de façon
caricaturale les anti vaccins ceux qui
sont vraiment opposées au vaccin
c'est une minorité ses 5 ou 10%
peut-être même pas et que les autres
personnes expriment une certaine
certaine réticence une certaine crainte
ce qui est légitime
à nous d'apporter le bon discours à nous
expliquer quel est l'intérêt du vaccin
est aujourd'hui non le discours
principal c c'est une immense
opportunité pour chacun d'entre nous
aussi bien sur le plan sanitaire sur le
plan social que sur le plan
économique et il est indispensable que
chacun d'entre nous comprenne qui
recevra xing pour lui qui un slovaque
sim pour les autres et pour toute la
société
c'est vraiment de l'engagement dans le
sens le plus noble du terme pour
protéger tous nos concitoyens alors en
général en que pensez vous de cette
campagne de vaccination son rythme son
est seulement là nous sommes dans les
premiers balbutiements vous voyez que on
vaccine les populations les plus
exposées au risque de décès au risque de
maladies au risque de décès c'est normal
qu'on protège d'abord les plus fragiles
et que peu à peu on élargissent les
frontières des personnes qui vont être
vaccinés
il faut rodez la mécanique il faut rodez
le système parce que c'est un circuit
logistique complexe mais je suis ultra
positive que nous devons tous être
optimiste sur cette campagne de
vaccination et sur sa réussite
la perspective n'est pas avoir à deux
mois mais très certainement à la fin de
l'été prochain au début du dos l'automne
ne pas avoir la crainte de devoir
affronter de nouvelles vagues
épidémiques comme celles que nous avons
déjà affronté deux vagues et la menace
d'en avoir encore une troisième ou une
quatrième
c'est vraiment une perspective colossal
et nous vivons une période extrêmement
moderne une véritable révolution dans le
monde de la médecine avec une arrivée
aussi rapide d'un vaccin pour un risque
épidémique nouveau c'est vraiment
quelque chose
ils doivent sous prendre et je le dis
donnez de la reconnaissance à tous ces
scientifiques avec tous ces gens qui ont
travaillé sur ces principes ces projets
maximum
alors vous êtes chef de service des
urgences de l'hôpital bichat justement
quelle est la situation actuelle 1
aujourd'hui dans votre hôpital dans nos
hôpitaux dont la plupart des centres
nous avons encore beaucoup de patients
je dirais que nous sommes à 60 50 ou 60%
de nos capacités dans les ide en
réanimation qui sont prises par des
patients qui ont le cofide qui ont la
colline
ce sont des patients qui sont arrivés
dans la deuxième vague épidémique et qui
sont encore en réanimation dont les
services d'urgence la situation est plus
sereine nous avons quelques cas que nous
diagnostiquons tous les jours nous avons
encore des patients que nous sommes
obligés d'hospitaliser aux médecines et
dans les lits de médecine il y a encore
une certaine partie de nos capacités
hospitalières qui sont prises par des
patients qui ont la combine
mais globalement la situation est
beaucoup moins tendue en tout cas sur
l'île de france
mais c'est vrai également dans d'autres
régions de france nous devons néanmoins
rester très difficile en continuant à
respecter les mesures barrières pour
éviter une reprise dynamique dès la fin
des fêtes
là c'est vraiment entre nos mains chaque
français a entre ses mains la
possibilité d'éditer une nouvelle vague
épidémique nouveau continent par
conséquent henrique casalino merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues et
chef de service des urgences de
l'hôpital bichat à paris mercier